we see logos for companies and places
every day but if you look closely at
them you can find some pretty cool
hidden meanings make sure you stay to
the end when we'll show you the hidden
message in the FedEx logo if this is
your first time visiting the things then
you should hit the subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're going to show you 10 famous logos
with a hidden meaning Bronx Zoo the
Bronx Zoo and New York City is the
largest city zoo in the United States of
America and it is one of the biggest
zoos anywhere in the world but as well
as the excellent conservation work they
do with the animals there is something
else that we like about them and that is
that they have an incredibly clever logo
when you first take a look at it it just
appears to be an image of giraffes and
birds that's still pretty cool but we
think you should take a look between the
giraffes legs and see what's there if
you look closely then you'll see that it
is actually a representation of the NYC
skyline lunatic something that some of
the best logos do is serve as a kind of
visual pun and that is what this next
logo does are you ready to see it okay
here you go it's for an online guessing
game called clue nitaac the purpose of
this game is to use a series of
different clues to identify a
personality what makes it different is
that every clue is a separate kind of
clue so it can be as exciting to come up
with a question as it is to find out
what the answer is and the logo is great
it's the letters that make the word clue
all boxed up and it's shaped like a key
to Picasa we think that the secret of
what makes a clever piece of company
branding is a combination of things a
logo needs to tell people a little bit
about what the brand does and who is
responsible for it that is why we really
like the Google Picasa logo if you look
at it it does all that firstly it has
the same colours as the distinctive
iconic Google script that we see online
pretty much every day and the colors are
all organized so that the logo looks
like a camera shutter and then the gap
in the shutter looks like a house or
casas in Spanish so everything is put
together brilliantly Carrefour if you
have ever visited France then you will
have almost certainly seen one of their
car for supermarkets they're in pretty
much any medium to large-sized town you
might visit in the country however they
also have a logo which contains a hidden
meaning if you take the time to have a
look at it if you
a bit of French you'll know that
Carrefour means crossroad and that's a
bit of a clue there the arrows in the
logo point to different directions which
helps you to reinforce the name which is
cool and if you look a bit closer then
you'll see that there is a letter C
hidden in there to Cisco when a company
is a real innovator they can do
something that can change the world
one great example of that is Cisco that
was the company that helped to create
the world wide web as we know it by
helping create and popularize local area
networks but as well as changing the way
we communicate we also like Cisco for
its logo if you take a quick look at it
it just looks like some vaguely
technological lines and dots but if you
pay close attention then you just might
see something else the lines form the
shape of the Golden Gate Bridge the
symbol of San Francisco the city from
which Cisco gets its name yoga Australia
one thing that helps give an image a
hidden meaning is the use of what
designers call negative space if you
aren't sure what that is it's the area
inside a drawn image if it is shaped in
the correct way
then it can become a new picture to
serve as a counterpoint with the main
image and one of the cleverest examples
that we know of is the logo for yoga
Australia can you see what's so clever
about it while you can see the
silhouette of a woman holding a yoga
pose obvious right but look at where she
is holding her ankle you can see the gap
is shaped like a map of Australia Sun
Microsystems in the world of puzzles
images and logos there is something
called an ambigram what an ambigram is
is something that reads the same
whichever way you turn it around and
that's something that's happened with
the logo of computing firm Sun
Microsystems no matter where you look on
the logo which appropriately enough for
a computing company he looks like a
microchip you read the words Sun
technically it's a rotationally
symmetric chain amber gram which is
impressive what is even more impressive
is that the man who designed it Vaughn
Pratt wasn't actually a designer he was
a computer science professor at Stanford
University USA and it was originally for
the Stanford University Network which is
where Sun Microsystems got its name from
McDonald's the golden arches of
McDonald's make up one of the biggest
best known and most iconic company logos
in the world the chances are you know
exactly what they look like there's a
very real chance that you have seen them
today but do you know their secret
meaning well we'll tell you first off
it's
is that they are an m4 McDonald's but
the story as to what they mean is pretty
interesting
in the 1960s McDonald's asked design
consultant and psychologist Lewis
chessmen for a new logo however mr. Ches
controlled them to keep with the golden
arches that was because their curves
resembled a part of a woman's anatomy
that is designed for feeding thus
linking the logo with nourishment Pepsi
if you are on the lookout for hidden
meanings and sometimes one thing can
have a range of different meanings if
you know where and how to look one great
example is the Pepsi logo for instance
if you flip it over it looks like is
dead which has led to Pepsi being asked
on some parts of the internet to see if
something survived an accident or it
could actually be a variety of smiling
and not smiling faces or otherwise it
just might be an overweight man who is
struggling to fit into his clothes but
whichever way you look at it it can mean
something even if that might not be what
the company intended FedEx FedEx is one
of the biggest delivery companies in the
world and it's got one of the cleverest
logos - when you first look at it it
just looks like the company's name but
look closer and you'll see something
very clever in between the E and the X
there's a space and that space looks
like an arrow it was put there by
designers Lyndon leader and Landor
associates in 1994 speed accuracy and
precision we think it's very clever but
we wondered are there any other logos
with hidden meanings that we might have
missed today don't be shy let us know
and tell us by leaving a comment that's
all for our 10 famous logos with a
hidden meaning thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]